what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm in my
home state of Chicago I'm actually in my
mom's office right now so shout out to
my mother for um letting me be at home I
am moving here semi-soon there's a
picture of my sister playing soccer if
you're wondering
um today before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel like the video
on your way in
um today I'm talking about my favorite
chick favorite celebrity lizzo lizzo
lizzo lizzo so who is lizzo you don't
know I'm sure most people do she is an
International world-renowned Celebrity
so lizzo I've really been listening to
since I was in high school and I
actually used to be a really big
fanalism
um I think she's a really talented
artist
um I think yeah it's really crazy how
she can move with all the weight she's
got but the last couple of years I
really started listening to her music a
bit more and listening to the lyrics and
really paying a little bit closer
attention to her on social media and
she's really been one of the pillars
celebrities of the body positive
movement this woman has been putting her
flab on the internet lizzo actually
threatened to quit music Imagine doing
something for 10 15 years threatening to
quit music and locks her Twitter account
after the latest wave of body shaving
from the Los Angeles time lizzo has been
an advocate for body positivity
celebrating plus size women and shooting
down fat phobic trolls while trying to
police that are trying to police her
body can you believe it who would try to
police someone's body but after a recent
encounter with body shaming comments the
Grammy award-winning artist is tired and
says she is close to quitting her music
career you want to come in you can you
can I showed you in this there's a
picture of you I just felt like I should
show because I love you sorry guys my
siblings they're just annoying all right
so but after a recent encounter with
body shaming comments the Grammy
award-winning artist is tired and said
she's close to quitting her music career
I hate it here lizzo wrote in a series
of tweets before locking her Twitter
account Wednesday according to multiple
Outlets that took screenshots of the
post lizzo locked her Twitter account
also in April y'all don't know how close
I'd be to giving up on everyone and
quitting and enjoying my money and my
man on a effing Farm the about damn time
singer was responding to a fat shaming
post from Leia Halpern also I'm a big
fan of Leia she's great she's in also
another red pill chick bitcoiner which
included a video of the artist dancing
on stage when captioned how is lizzo
still this fat when she's constantly
moving on stage I wonder what she must
be eating guys that's a valid question I
mean think about it if you're burning
that many calories every day it's a
valid question I just logged onto this
app and this is the type of [__] I see
on a daily basis
then someone in the comments said I eat
a lot of fast food I literally stopped
eating fast food years ago and I'm tired
of explaining myself all the time and I
just want to get on this app without
seeing my name in some [__] in
another response to the Tweet which
since has been deleted that said I don't
think lizzo wants to be salt smaller
because it's her brand lizzo clapped
back I'm not trying to be fat I'm not
trying to be smaller I'm literally just
trying to live and be healthy this is
what my body looks like even when I'm
eating super clean and working out okay
guys I need to just I'm gonna I'm gonna
continue the article but I'm gonna I'm
just gonna pull up her Instagram I'm not
I'm not gonna say any words okay I'm
just gonna pull up some pictures and
I'll let you guys decide for yourself
eating clean eating super healthy and I
and I relate like I I struggle with
eating so much I had some Buffalo Wild
Wings last night and I went home and I
felt ashamed but gosh I'm in the U.S and
I just I miss the food I don't lie to
you okay so throughout her career lizzo
has been outspoken about body positivity
and has built a lucrative Empire while
doing so she has designed okay so she's
saying she's she's not about body
positivity okay but let's look at this
is why you can't listen to things that
women say because you have to watch what
we do and she then then has a shapewear
line called Yeti which is designed for
all body shapes what is shapewear do it
holds in your blubber like if I had
shapewear right now I would look like I
had a six-pack it would be like a it's
literally like if you're so body
positive why do you need to pull in the
blubber be positive put it all out there
don't suck it in in 2022 and also and
she's saying my brand isn't body
positivity well you have a shapewear
line be real body positive sell a
workout Pro call me crazy all right in
2022 she also launched the Emmy women
Prime video called lizzo watch out for
big girls okay so your brand isn't body
positivity but you have a show called
lizzo's watch out for big girls when
Adele was big she didn't do this and
this is what we're talking about women
they Gaslight this is a gas lighting
technique she's like I am not about body
positivity but you have a shapewear line
and you had a reality show called lizzo
watch out for big girls in which so what
does she do on the show I wonder maybe
it's not about big girls maybe it's
nothing to do with your body in which
she searches out plus size dancers to
join her on tour so not the best dancers
not the most talented dancers not the
people in the best shape because I'd
imagine if you're dancing you know if
you're shimmying you got to be in shape
but plus size dancing those are the
Articles words if we're looking for the
best dancers what does body have to do
with it unless it's part of your brand
okay although the recent wave of fat
shaming comments has pushed lizzo off of
Twitter she followed up up her tweets by
posting a video to her Instagram
Wednesday from a performance in the
message I'm sorry people on Twitter suck
you're beautiful and special now this is
the delusion yeah okay like maybe guys
in the comments correct me if I'm wrong
I don't know maybe I don't know what I'm
talking about is this beautiful this is
corn this is corn like you don't have to
lead with your weight there have been
big celebrities that none of us
conservative media types go after or
care about because they don't lead with
their weight Adele I was looking at
Adele's pictures let's let's pull up
Adele's Instagram I was I was looking
and this is a woman with 54 million
followers okay so freaking talented she
lost the weight but I was looking at her
Instagram from when she was big nobody
talked about this picture nobody cared
everyone loves Adele and when I say when
I make fun of the whales and the big
women I'm not talking about women that
don't lead with that we all have our
struggles in life right mine is sugar
addiction
um and luckily I've built really good
habits of working out over but you know
we all have our struggles but there's a
difference between working on our
struggles and trying to improve and
accepting them and pushing them is a
positive thing oh shoot all right now
we'll keep I will never shut up about
how difficult y'all make make it for fat
people to exist oh my gosh you know what
it's like we're just existing on
Instagram okay we're just and You Adele
Adele who know you know children follow
you
um I followed you when I was younger
like is this leading with your talent
and you have to think about Guys these
are the pictures that she chooses to
give the world this is how she chooses
to represent herself and she leads with
her weight and then gets mad when people
criticize her weight you know it would
be one thing if we were going after
Adele get it back when she was big
getting the most unflattering pictures
of her and making a whole campaign
against it but it's like this woman this
is all over her Instagram all over this
isn't just like she's either wearing
skin tight outfits that show every
blubber she's shaking her blubber like
this is I I finally see one of her
singing thank you God I love you you are
beautiful and you can do anything is she
not even singing oh my gosh and it
doesn't even oh my gosh now let's go to
our Tick Tock maybe your Tick Tock is
better oh
okay so this one I'm thinking okay this
is good she's talking finally see The
Little Mermaid Nearly Naked can be kind
of a struggle to put on because it's so
snatchy lizzo lizzo and this is the
thing I understand how hard it is to
lose weight I I understand the sugar
addictions the eating like seriously I
literally struggle with it but it's like
when you're that's what you're leading
with what do you expect to happen it's
so oh my God oh my gosh
lizzo is on tour in support of her 2022
album special which nabbed a Grammy
nomination including a stop in November
at the Kia Forum in Inglewood throughout
the summer she'll be playing at
festivals blah blah blah and now let's
let's look at the response does does
anybody hold her accountable or do they
Pander it's exhausting no matter how
much you achieve here comes the mallow
content commenting on your body and the
cruelest and stupidest ways and nothing
pithy will undo the harm just know you
don't know anyone an explanation for who
you are you're a beautiful queen you're
a beautiful kiween and other people are
ugly just trying to be seen yeah
oh oh my God
oh
wow
run don't walk
why why do people comment on my ways
sometimes I wish I wasn't giddy so I
could just talk about how amazing it he
is this dress is so [__] cute
you guys the women are the meanest
because you guys encourage this look at
lizzo I just seem to say this to you I
doubt you'll see this but look this
stuff isn't healthy it's not cute and it
takes away from your actual talent God
has given you a natural Get Talent to
create good music upbeat uplifting and
you're choosing to drown out your talent
by promoting fatness and yes it is
promoting it when it's all over your
Instagram it's all over your Tick Tock
and that is the thing you are leading
with in every room and I don't care if
your friends around you are hyping you
up I don't care if your boyfriend your
scent boyfriend Hypes you up I don't
really care if the internet Hypes you up
it's not cute and it's sad because you
have so much to offer the world and yet
you are still leading with your fatness
when you should be leading with your
talent and that is what you are
promoting and you are promoting to
younger women that it is okay and that
will let you be happy and you are
beautiful just the way you are where you
know that is not true you will and if
you continue to gain weight you won't
get the type of guy that you could and
men do not like fat chicks women don't
even really like the way it looks the
only reason women push you on is because
now you're not competition okay now the
other thing I wanted to point out about
lizzo you know if we want to talk about
hurting someone or like if we want to
talk about attacking someone for just
existing let's talk about how lizzo
attacks men for just existing her hit
song the truth hurts and I have to say I
used to love this song but I never
really listened to the lyrics and then
it's funny I memorized these lyrics
without even really thinking about what
she was saying what they met why men
great till they gotta be great I just
took a DNA test and it turns out I'm 100
that [__] even when I'm crying crazy
yeah I got boy problems that's the human
in me bling bling then I solve them
that's the goddess in me you could have
had a bad [__] non-committal helped you
with your curvier just a little you're
supposed to hold me down but now you're
holding me back and this is the sound of
me not calling you back so she starts
off saying why are men great until they
gotta be great so now she's [__] on
men for just existing okay she took a
DNA test turns out I'm 100 that [__] it
sounds like she's dating some bummy men
because you could have had a bad [__]
non-committal so she's not committing to
him and he helped you with your career
like what what guys do you want to date
to help with your career all right why
men great till they gotta be great don't
text me tell it straight to my face best
friend sat me down in the salon chair
shampoo shampoo press gets you out of my
hair fresh photos with the bomb lighting
new man on the Minnesota Viking truth
hurts I needed something more exciting
you know I mean it's catchy it's catchy
but the issue is that again we're we're
promoting this like boss [__] like oh
dear like the issue is like we have open
missandry in a song that's how she's
starting and she's gonna play victim and
say that oh I'm the I'm the victim
they're coming at me for just existing
when she's putting out fat pictures on
the internet nobody comes at Jennifer
Hudson who's bigger for just existing
nobody came at Adele for just existing
there are tons of artists Kelly Clarkson
nobody at me a little bit but nobody
really comes at her like they come at
lizzo for just existing we come at
artists that lead with their fact
instead of their talent and lizzo knows
that she would not be as big and get as
much attention she didn't I have a
proposition for Liz lizzo I have a I
live on 40 acres I have a whole gym and
I will work out with you for three
months and help you with your eating and
we'll get in a nutritionist and yeah I'm
here to give you a solution you don't
have to be fat you don't have to live
like this you can lose the weight you
can be healthier you can live longer
because the way you're going You're
Gonna Die Young you're gonna die of a
heart attack you're not you're clearly
not whatever food even if it's not fast
food it's clearly not healthy because
you're crazy obese and if you're eating
healthy and you're still obese there's
clearly a problem let's fix it so open
invite to lizzo please send her this
video and tell her she's invited to work
out with me let me know in the comments
am I off base do we feel bad for lizzo
um let me know maybe I'm wrong like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time